Hi, my name is Charles Ying.
I'm one of the cofounders
of PixVerse.
PixVerse is a next-generation
virtual world company.
We were recently acquired
by hi5 Networks,
the fastest-growing
social network.
Today, I'm gonna be talking
about PixChat,
our real-time chat room that we
built using Google App Engine.
So let's get started.
So this is PixChat here,
running on my hi5 homepage.
This is running
in the open social platform.
So to give you a brief overview
of PixChat...
PixChat seems a little confusing
at first,
but basically what you have here
on the left
are people viewing the PixChat
from anywhere on the Web.
So either on a profile page
or on any Web page
you've embedded
this chat room on.
On the right-hand side
you can see people
who are active--
actively chatting.
And mixed in as well
are notes, stickers,
and photos people have left
onscreen
for other people
to see.
So what I'll show here
is--
this is a chat going on.
As people enter and leave,
they'll sometimes chat.
I can even type in a message,
like, "hello?"
It'll show up here.
I can even move
my avatar around,
so it comes up here.
So people can see me better.
I can even check out
people's profiles
if I want, or I can chat
with them privately
as well.
I can also embed
this chat room on any Web page
I want just by copying
the embed code here.
I can now also add things
like--
I can change the backgrounds,
I can change this to a...
brown background.
And here you can see
the background has changed
instantly in real time.
I can add stickers.
So I can put some sushi,
maybe a spinning wheel,
a teddy bear,
and a cookie,
and they all appear on here.
So here's one
of the teddy bears.
You can move around
and put him here.
I can write notes
to people.
I can also add photos.
I'm gonna add a photo.
Let's see.
That one.
And this one.
And they appear instantly here.
So here's one of the photos.
And I can just zoom in.
And it'll zoom in on it.
You can see
the whole photo here.
If there are other photos
people have put online,
you can see them
as well.
It's basically photo-sharing.
I can also search
for videos.
So here's a search
for App Engine.
So I'm gonna pull
out the campfire video
and stick it on the page.
And that showed up here.
And I can play it.
And it plays it
straight from YouTube.
(man on video)
Hi, everyone.
(Charles)
Right here from YouTube.
And I'll just close that.
And that's pretty much
a tour of PixChat.
Just to show what happens
when you put it across the Web.
You can take the embed code
and put it anywhere,
but PixChat also appears
on your profile.
So here's a profile page
with a smaller version
of the chat window
running here.
So you basically have
a chat room
that can be embedded anywhere
instantly.
And I can even copy
and paste that
and put that
on any Web page,
just like we've done
on our main homepage
here as well.
The way we built PixChat
on App Engine was,
we ported WebPI, which was
only a few lines of code
and didn't take very long
to run
on top of App Engine's
Python framework.
Um, it was really easy.
And we were able
to start serving
our open social gadgets,
our Flash animations,
and our Flash clients
all from App Engine.
And the real-time aspect
of the system
is using
our real-time servers,
but everything else runs
on App Engine.
In terms of the--
the--
the user's
last-visited location
and the presence information,
we store those
using the Datastore API
and the memcache API.
And we use keys
to speed up the queries.
And we use memcache to--
it's really very easy.
Just a few lines
of code added in
to make things work great.
And the whole porting effort
for our prototype took
only three hours
to put together.
And we had the whole system
up and running.